allons vous emmène ce soir en auvergne
rhône-alpes l'une des rares régions où
un candidat n'est pas vraiment menacé ni
par le rn ni par la gauche ni par la
république en marche c'est laurent
wauquiez peut-être de liste lr et udi
en tout cas au premier tour le sortant
fait la course en tête et il est loin
devant les autres les enjeux et la
campagne sur le terrain c'est avec
audrey buts à zéro man bout dit laurent
wauquiez
manille le tutoiement avec les
agriculteurs du cantal il faut dire
qu'il est en territoire ami en 2015 le
département rural lui a donné plus de
50% de voix
ce jour là le candidat à sa réélection
vient leur rappeler qu'il a toujours été
là pour eux en retour mais je vois pas
l'étiquette de la région depuis que je
suis arrivé les aides de la région sur
le cantal ça fait x 4 parfois un parfois
deux ça fait x 4 même s'il fait la
course largement en tête avec plus de 10
points d'avancé dans les sondages il
tient à sécuriser ces voies savez une
élection avait jamais joué on a essayé
juste de montrer que la région faisait
pas des miracles mais qu'elle était
utile on l'a montré au moment du coc
vide on l'a montré sur les sujets
agricoles sur les questions de sécurité
la sécurité l'une des priorités de
laurent wauquiez dans cette campagne
tout comme la préférence régionale
aujourd'hui quand même pour que vous
sachiez j'ai des problèmes où j'ai des
exploitations qui sont dans l'aveyron
qui sont dans la lozère qui sont dans la
creuse et qui demande à localiser le
siège de l'exploitation chez nous donc
nous il faut qu'on arrive à tenir avec
ces thématiques il laboure le terrain du
rassemblement national en deuxième
position certains militants du rn 10
même qu'il les assèche alors andrea
quotas rac la tête de liste tente
d'imposer son image comme il le peut
vous avez vu ça passe pas inaperçu quand
on va dans les villages à bord de sa
cote à mobile le transfuge de la france
insoumise cible les villages d
industrialiser à chaque fois il martèle
sa différence avec laurent wauquiez on a
deux approches sont complètement
différentes
lui souhaite je crois deux agents de
sécurité par lycée ça n'a aucun sens il
ya des lycées où on n'a pas besoin
d'agents de sécurité puis en a d'autres
où deux ne pourront pas faire le travail
on a deux conceptions différentes sur la
sécurité on a deux conceptions
différentes sur l'islamisme
moi je suis parti de la france est
soumise précisément
parce que les concepts d'islam au
gauchisme l'indigénisme avec gangréné
l'ensemble de la gauche lui dit qu'il
est contre l'islamisme et on voit sur sa
liste des députés verts qui sont
complaisants avec l'islamisme
communautarisme face à eux bruno bonnell
le candidat l hérault m joue la carte de
l'optimisme prêt à déplacer des
montagnes
ou plutôt à les creuser il est en visite
ce jour là sur le chantier d'un tunnel
oui on se rend pas compte mais ces
grands quand même pour la future ligne
ferroviaire lyon-turin faut être
radicalement optimisant cette campagne
n'est pas simplement pour être le ravi
de la crèche fait optimiste parce qu'à
côté des discours de désespérance que
j'entends du front national de l'anxiété
qu'on entretient avec la gouvernance
actuelle
faut arrêter de désespérer notamment les
jeunes générations moi j'ai un plan sur
trente ans pour cette région un plan de
développement économique
je crois que c'est la prospérité qui
amène les quitter et qui amène la
fraternité si certains candidats aux
régionales gomme leurs liens avec le
parti au pouvoir
lui en est fier on a eu un président qui
a tenu la barre on n'est pas dans la
situation d'autres pays européens grâce
au courage de cette majorité
présidentielle
il s'affiche même avec des ministres
comme ici son ami joël giraud en charge
de la ruralité à gauche socialistes et
écologistes ont fait le choix du divorce
temporaire les retrouvailles auront lieu
le soir du premier tour la liste qui
arrivera en tête mènera la bataille du
second scrutin
bon allez voir les agriculteurs bio
l'écologiste fabienne grébert en
campagne depuis novembre compte bien
surfer sur la vague verte des
municipales naos pillay sont très très
bon là ici dans la haute-loire de
laurent wauquiez elle est venue montrer
que l'écologie n'est pas qu'une affaire
de bobo il s'en prend directement au
président sortant il dépense énormément
d'argent public pour sa propre
communication depuis des années donc
c'est la moindre des choses qu'ils
soient devant mais je sens aujourd'hui
et tous les gens sur la campagne sentent
que le projet écologiste est un projet
qui porte qu'à une aspiration à la
qualité de vie et l'art on a un effet de
levier formidable pour développer des
filières économiques
ici par exemple sur le vivant sur le
bois
l'ancien ministre de l'éducation najat
vallaud belkacem faite avec cette
campagne son retour en politique
un retour compliqué les sondages lui
donnent 11% des voix dans une région
pourtant gouverné par le ps il est
encore six ans malgré sa popularité elle
peine à mobiliser les électeurs cerne
mal les dates et les enjeux du scrutin
[Musique]
comme la confusion la plus grande s'est
installé sur les compétences de la
région les gens n'ont pas conscience que
s'ils n'ont pas pu se former aux métiers
qu'ils auraient voulu exercer en se
reconvertissant ces deux attaques aux de
la région parce qu'elle a coupé tous les
fonds de la formation professionnelle si
ils ont pas pu se loger parce qu'elle
n'est pas suffisamment de logements
sociaux c'est parce que la région n'a
pas financé ces logements sociaux il ya
quand même beaucoup de perdants à la
politique de monsieur évoqué dans cette
région et ses perdants là je peux vous
dire qu'ils ont besoin d'une alternative
la candidate fait de la pédagogie et va
chercher les électeurs un à un chaque
voix compte car pour l'instant même si
la gauche unie au second tour laurent
wauquiez est donné largement gagnant
et comme tous les jours par souci
d'équité je vous invite à lire
l'ensemble des listes candidates en
auvergne rhône-alpes le voici les noms
des neuf têtes de liste je vous rappelle
d'ailleurs que le premier tour a lieu
dimanche prochain édition spéciale dès
22 heures sur les chaînes parlementaires
je serai aux côtés de brigitte boucher
pour les présenter j'aurai cet honneur
avec nous pour le match des idées ce
soir florent vadillo bienvenue du
président du think tank letteri
conseiller municipal ps à périgueux
vice-président du grand périgueux et
ancien conseiller spécial de jean
jacques urvoas avec nous également
nicolas tenzer bienvenue vous êtes
philosophe essayiste président fondateur
du centre d'étude et de réflexion pour
l'action politique et directeur de la
revue le banquet merci à tous les deux
si on s'arrête une minute sur le cas
précis de la région euro vers le rhône
alpes dont on vient de voir un reportage
il faut admettre que laurent wauquiez
florent vadillo est l'un des rares à ne
pas être menacé par le rassemblement
national
c'est encore un poid lourd ya encore des
poids lourds chez allaire qui tiennent
qui tiennent la baraque j'ai envie de
dire humblement
au demeurant les poids lourds de droite
sont ceux qui résistent le mieux parce
que xavier bertrand même s'il n'est plus
à l air on peut considérer que c'est un
compagnon de route au demeurant laurent
wauquiez après sa sortie à la présidence
de l air était un peu amoché il a su
parfaitement faire une vraie cure de
politique nationale en étant loin de la
scène nationale il s'est rebâti une
stature de président de région qu'il
avait quand même largement délaissées et
puis il n'est pas concurrencés par le
rassemblement national parce que il faut
reconnaître que la thématique de laurent
wauquiez de longue date c'est quand même
d'aller chasser sur les terres du front
national
il est loin le temps où laurent wauquiez
était l'héritier spirituel de jacques
barrot maintenant il a pris la ligne
dure du sarkozysme et ce qui lui avait
été reproché d'ailleurs à la tête du
parti à juste titre et c'est un calcul
électoral qu'on peut comprendre la
question qui se pose c'est de savoir si
c'est viable dans le temps elle son
élection où sa défaite nous le dira et 2
quels traumatismes cela induit sur la
vie politique parce que cette course
après l'électorat et rennes sur les
thèmes du rassemblement national
in fine et profite au rassemblement
national on le voit je prends un exemple
en bretagne le rassemblement s'est
nationale n'existait pas aujourd'hui il
est en passe d'être le premier parti ce
qui est un traumatisme et je crois que
la classe politique qui a couru sur ce
thème l'un a une responsabilité on verra
si ça lui portera chance lorsqu'elle est
bien là la menace et nicolas tenzer pour
ces élections régionales elle est là
elle est là d'ailleurs on le voit
évidemment en provence alpes côte d'azur
notamment
malgré tout comme un petit peu dans le
temps les autres france même si quand
même vis-à-vis bertrand semble quand
même assuré de l'emporter
mais c'est surtout comme le disait
florent radio c'est vrai que c'est
derrière la thématique qui est très
inquiétant que c'est à dire qu'on
banalise et quand on voit un certain
nombre de valeurs je parle pas
uniquement de laurent wauquiez qui sont
prêts même à torpiller certains des
leurs ou le lance anciens collègues de l
heure pour éventuellement aller voter
pour des candidats du rassemblement
national au prétexte est une vieille
formule 1 qu'il n'y aurait pas d'ennemi
à droite on peut vraiment s'interroger
sur le titre les républicains qu'est-ce
que ça de républicains que le front
national va le rassemblement national ça
plus rien et puis il n'ya plus ses
valeurs de base qui était celle de
l'ancien parti gaulliste alors il était
parfois un peu amoché mais toujours dans
les marges là on voit quand même
beaucoup de leaders qui sont totalement
décomplexé par rapport à cette droite
dure est-ce à dire al qu'est-ce que ça
dira de la future présidentielle si une
région bascule bel et bien voir deux au
rassemblement national je crois que ça
installera définitivement le front
national le rassemblement national comme
le premier parti de france
un moment donné il faut dire les choses
telles qu'elles sont sur les derniers
scrutins municipal excepté même si une
très forte poussée
le rassemblement national s'installe
durablement dans le paysage politique
français je rappel c'est le premier
parti aux élections européennes aux
élections municipales très forte
progression des sénateurs des parlements
des députés aujourd'hui sans doute des
présidents de région il faudra donc se
poser la question de quelle est la vie
politique qui se structure avec un
rassemblement national qui est un acteur
à part entière
on a des exemples l'autriche par exemple
avec très clairement un accord entre la
droite et le rassemblement national
triste très simplement 2022 la question
qui se pose c'est les républicains vente
il basculé avec lrm ou avec le
rassemblement national pour moi c'est la
seule configuration du paysage politique
est à attendre
elle est on va parler de l'actualité
internationale messieurs elle est
marquée par la présence sur le sol
européen
vous avez échappé de joe biden le
président américain est donc à bruxelles
pour un sommet de l'otan une réunion
avec les dirigeants de l'union
européenne
on parle même de retrouvailles entre
l'amérique et ses alliés relation un peu
malmené pendant la présidence de donald
trump avant d'y revenir avec vous sur ce
plateau on va accueillir dans ce match
des idées caroline galak terros bonsoir
vous êtes géopolitologue présidente du
think tank géo pragma qui se présente
comme un pôle français de géopolitique
réaliste merci d'être avec nous ce soir
un président américain en europe c'est
toujours un événement mais est ce que le
fait que ce soit joe biden c'est
particulier ce que vous diriez même
qu'il y a une petite byden magna en
europe
bah écoutez on passe d'une manière sans
doute mais ils font pas il faut pas trop
prêter le flanc aux au flon flon et à la
cosmétique
ce qui est certain c'est que cette
nouvelle administration est vu et
étaient de position premières sont vus
comme une bouée par les européens qui
qui ne savent pas ils ne veulent pas
réfléchir tout seul à leur propre alors
pour preuve d'intérêt et positionnement
donc je dirais que c'est rassurant
d'obéir et de ce point de vue là on est
ravi que joe biden soit là est-ce que ça
va être très différent de la pale trump
sur le fond je n'en suis pas certaine
je pense que même si notre président
macron dans dans la conférence de presse
qui a précédé le g7 a expliqué que le
leadership de tels partenariats
c'est beau mais c'est assez tôt à
nietzsche parce que on n'est pas
vraiment les partenaires on est on est
essentiellement des vassaux plus ou
moins consentant on veut l'ignorer on
déteste qu'on nous dise en public et
qu'est ce que disait c'est ce que
j'avais 30
mais la réalité c'est que les états unis
reprennent normal europe
le sommet de l'otan va d'ailleurs à mon
avis il le montrer assez clairement et
et fait de nous mettre en ordre de
marche
sérieux et discipliné vis-à-vis de ses
propres priorités qui sont bien là le
combat prête à lâcher le combat après ça
la russie anglais ne se sent pas nos
zélites bon point de vue donc il
faudrait pas qu'on continue dans
l'hystérie à la diabolisation parce que
malheureusement on est dans un tournant
real il de relations internationales il
faut effectivement aller vers du
dialogue du partenariat
peut-être que le sommet du 16 entre joe
biden et vladimir poutine va permettre
d'être une forme de d'équilibrage en
tout cas dans l'est dans les discours et
dans les dents les attentes peut-être
aussi d'ailleurs quelques applis de
caddie les traits blancs il a remarqué
que pour une fois on parlait d'un
équilibre à la fin entre dans les
relations d'un équilibre qui était
comment virer joue chaque partie avait
la responsabilité dans cet équilibre
dans la mise en oeuvre de ce
déséquilibre entre le jeu et la russie
est évidemment entre l'amérique et là
aussi parce que pour la russie c'est
quand même le dialogue avec l'amérique
qui prime sur tout alors vous avez dit
beaucoup de choses on va y revenir un
peu plus tôt évidemment je vous donnerai
la parole régulièrement nicolas tenzer
est-ce que biden arrive en europe en
donnant le la est ce qu'il arrive pour
reprendre en à l'europe dont il ne
reprend pas en main l'europe il ya un
partenariat très équilibré entre les
européens et joe biden c'est une réalité
joe biden est un homme de dialogue est
un homme qui respecte les autres qui
respecte l'europe c'est l'un des rares
présidents américains qui est vraiment
très européen depuis george bush père je
crois et qui a d'ailleurs reconnu que la
contribution de l'union européenne à la
fois la sécurité à la marche du monde
était absolument décisive
maintenant en europe nous avons les
mêmes ennemis et j'insiste sur le terme
et demi que l'amérique que la russie
d'abord et la chine qui sont deux états
qui commettent des crimes de guerre
voire des crimes contre l'humanité des
crimes de génocide qui cherchent à nous
déstabiliser et je crois que nous
n'avons intérêt même si nous avons
parfois des désaccords avec les états
unis tout à fait normaux sur le plan
commercial encore qui en est -
d'ailleurs que qu'on le pensait au début
avant l'arrivée de joe biden nous avons
intérêt à ce qu'il y ait un front commun
et ce n'est que s'il ya un front commun
y compris dans la lutte contre la
kleptocratie y compris contre la
corruption de ce régime contre les
menaces aux hybrides contre les
violations graves des droits de l'homme
que nous pourrons résister à ces menaces
nous avons été passifs jusqu'à présent
extrêmement passif et je pense que
maintenant est venue l'heure de l'action
et je crois que les dirigeants européens
pour la plupart d'entre eux pas tous
malheureusement on comprit très bien
quels étaient les véritables menaces la
russie étant la plus immédiate la plus
dure la chine étant la plus importante à
moyen terme
je crois qu'il faut bien avoir cette
vision commune et je crois que l'idée de
dire que l'europe devrait chercher une
sorte d'équilibré aurait une puissance
d'équilibré n'y a absolument rien dire
entre d'un côté les états unis et la
russie et la chine de l'autre en les
mettant sur le même plan là strictement
aucune signification en termes de
menaces et en termes précisément réalise
nous avons les mêmes ennemis flore radio
que les états unis en tout cas il est
indéniable que dans le conflit qui peut
nous opposer parfois des grandes
puissances la chine est un régime
totalitaire
la russie est un régime autoritaire nous
ne partageons pas les mêmes valeurs et
surtout nous n'avons pas la même manière
de pratiquer la diplomatie on le voit la
diplomatie russe où la diplomatie
chinoise et une diplomatie agressive de
vassalisation de conflits assumer et de
provocation parfois ce qui n'est pas le
cas des états unis la relation avec les
états unis elle jeu j'ai un petit
désaccord elle et elle n'est pas aussi
équilibré qu'on pourrait le croire un
peu de vassalisation aussi avec le terme
de vassalisation parce que ça
impliquerait qu'ils une stratégie
déployée et parfois de 2,2 de mépris à
l'égard de ses partenaires je crois que
les états unis ont une vision il jauge
le nombre de puits la puissance de leurs
partenaires des états unis joe biden de
sûr mais là encore je je je crois que il
y as au delà effectivement de trump
hayden
il y à une administration il ya une
politique américaine qui connaît mal gré
des variations quelques invariants et le
fait que l'europe parfois on regarde
par-dessus l'europe et notamment verra
si aujourd'hui les états unis sont
préoccupés de l'asie du développement
asiatique l'europe est un partenaire on
a besoin de l'europe pour la stabilité
du monde mais ça n'est pas le partenaire
immédiat et premier que les états unis
veulent avoir donc je crois qu'il faut
être très clair sur les combats nicolas
tenzer le rappelle à juste titre la
russie et la chine ne partage pas la
vision du monde que l'on veut de
démocratie que l'on veut et donc il de
ce point de vue là il faut les combattre
quand ensuite a su réagir sur des
agressions je rappelle qu'en terme par
exemple d'espionnage économique
les américains sont très bien placés en
termes de prédation de notre patrimoine
économique au même titre que le sont les
russes ou les chinois donc il y a un
rapport de puissance qu'il faut savoir
équilibrer ne pas céder à la baille de
magna mais rappelez quand même où sont
nos intérêts effectivement il y a des
ennemis en relations internationales
carling acteos vous craignez que
l'europe soit naïve avec joe biden vous
craignez que emmanuel macron soit naïf à
l'égard de joe biden ou pas je pense
qu'il a fait des déclarations je pense
j'ai vu en amont du g7 qui étaient des
déclarations intelligent qu'il a
l'habitude moulin à nouveau partenariat
avec les états unis il a dit qu'il ne
voulait pas que l'otan soit réorientée
contre pékin donc la notion d'ennemi à
mon avis est une notion extrêmement
mauvaises et contre-productive
les relations internationales fans et ça
n'est pas du tout ça et c'est
certainement elles ont pris un tournant
réaliste radical est vrai dire
l'occident doite doit le comprendre et
doit et doit chercher justement
déséquilibre et pas des confrontations
brutales unilatérale en l'embarquant
derrière la bannière américaine
une europe qui elle a tout à perdre at
place à mon avis maintenant on peut
idéologie d tout mais je pense justement
que l'intérêt de cette période quelques
petits milliers d autocrate rider
dictature qui démocratise de toute façon
il n'ya plus à vrai dire de canons et de
prétention accepté par quiconque
sur quelle planète à apprendre des
leçons de l'occident dont on peut avoir
une valeur nos pratiques nos intérêts et
évidemment on doit à tenir compte de ce
qu'il y a
et ne pas sous-estimer les menaces aller
dans l'hostilité dans le bellicisme
avéré assume et avec en fait à me semble
complètement ridicule et comme sur
beaucoup de terrain de confrontation au
moyen orient en afrique et ailleurs
nous n'avons que des que des coups à
prendre à ce manichéisme
alors bien sûr et enfin enfin d'humanité
florent amadio
je suis un peu surpris parce que si on
veut parler de bellicisme je rappelle
que pour l'instant il n'y a que la
russie et la chine dans le dialogue des
grandes puissances qui disposent de
cellules de déstabilisation de la vie
politique occidentale qu'il s'agisse aux
états unis ou en europe avec très
clairement des fermes de bottes destinée
à influencer le vote des électeurs ce
sont les seuls puissance de ce rang là
qu'ils ont cette capacité là donc il ya
des ingérences très grave et je rappelle
également dans le domaine cyber que ce
sont les seules puissances également
qu'ils assument des actes qui sont
destinés à déstabiliser les démocraties
aujourd'hui vous avez des attaques cyber
commandité par la russie et la chine
dont le seul objectif est de
déstabiliser les régimes politiques
en d'autres temps c'étaient des actes de
guerre qui conduisait à des conflits
armés
aujourd'hui ce sont d'autres rapports de
force mais n'allons pas dire tous ne
l'ont pas de terre l'hostilité déclarée
l'organisation étatique de ces pays à
notre rencontre
en quelques mots nicolas tenzer en
passerelle à suffisait pour revoilà ce à
propos de l'hostilité et je veux dire
c'est quand même la russie malgré tout
qui a annexé la crimée en 2014 qui était
la première annexion d'un pays par la
force sur le territoire européen depuis
l'annexion des sudètes par hitler qui a
envahi le dans de basses qui a commis
des crimes de guerre en syrie on appuie
à bachar el assad qui soutient
aujourd'hui le dictateur sanglant
sanguinaire
bella russo bélarusses loukachenko et
qui commet des assassinats notamment sur
le sol européen
donc je pense que ça fait quand même un
tout petit peu beaucoup donc le problème
des actes de guerre c'est qu'ils ne
viennent pas de chez nous ils viennent
bien de ces puissances pour la chine on
pourrait bien sûr aussi ajouter la
violation que de l'accord de
rétrocession à hong kong avec la
privation de liberté totale dans ce pays
et les crimes de génocide commis contre
les ouigours et ça je pense que si nous
avons une dignité si nous croyons au
droit international nous ne pouvons pas
laisser faire parce que tout simplement
ça voudrait dire que c'est puissant se
sentent une sorte de droit d'agir un
droit d'ingérence absolue un droit
d'annexion un droit de violer ses droits
et ça je pense qu'il faut un certain
moment mettre le holà je voudrais qu'on
revienne et rester avec nous peut-être
caroline caractères hausse le sujet va
vous intéresser
sur l'autre événement international du
moment c'est la fin des douze ans de
règne de benyamin nétanyahou en israël
le parlement a donc voté la confiance du
gouvernement du nouveau premier ministre
l'aft ali bennett coalition qui va de la
droite à la gauche qui a provoqué des
scènes de liesse vous les avez peut-être
vu hier soir à tel aviv regarder on va
écouter d'ailleurs une habitante qui a
été interrogée par la seule agence
france presse hier soir à bissau
c
ce n'est pas le gouvernement dont j'ai
rêvé mais c'est absolument le
gouvernement parfait pour le peuple
israélien
parce que chaque parti représente
d'autres secteurs et donc dans
l'ensemble c'est le gouvernement d'unité
parfaite dont nous avons besoin à ce
stade de notre vie parce que nous avons
les religieux nous avons les gens de
gauche
les gens de droite et les arabes tous
ensemble ils ont des intérêts mutuels et
ça va être bien
je l'espère mais ça devrait être bien si
leurs intentions sont pures
ça devrait être bien caroline guay
l'acte héros sont assortis cet extrait
parce que elle nous a paru assez mesuré
cette habitante de tel aviv en parlant
de d'un gouvernement pas parfait qui
part un peu dans tous les sens
effectivement mais qui est peut-être le
gouvernement adapté pour ce moment là en
israël après 12 ans netanyahu qu'en
pensez vous écoutez alors moi je pense
que oui c'est un fait une coalition très
près de peroxyde qui va vraiment parce
que il est à la droite du likoud
quand même donc là il a fait est
incertain c'est 1 à 1 tour passe pas
politique ou institutionnel il s'est
allié avec un centriste on peut espérer
que ce soit plus représentatif mais je
ne suis pas sûr que la société
israélienne soit si à gauche que cela
est aussi modérée quête d'armes
si c'est ça ce n'est pas vivable je
l'écouté je pense que netanyahou n'a
absolument pas dit son dernier mot que
il va essayer d'être le chef de file
d'une nouvelle opposition large à la
knesset et qu'on n'a pas du tout finie
on très active à la knesset et que quand
même le likoud est le plus grand parti
du parlement israélien toujours et
je ne suis pas sûr que tout cela dure
longtemps je pense surtout qu israël est
dans une crise à la fois intérieure est
écrite à lourdes et que le problème de
fond est bien c'est que via une
instabilité politique en israël qu'il a
demeuré et que par ailleurs à l'échelle
régionale déquilibre bouge et mettre en
porte-à-faux un peu israël notamment par
rapport à ce qu'on appelle lé dakor
d'abraham qui vivait à oublier autour
d'israël
un certain nombre des pays de la région
et qui sont désormais malmené par le
dialogue est en train malgré tout de
reprendre entre l'iran et l'arabie
saoudite ont de leur présence a fait
long à expliquer mais donc il y à un
environnement régional de cette nouvelle
situation politique
il ya bien sûr la renégociation en cours
en tout cas on pour parler de l'accord
nucléaire sur le nucléaire iranien
et tout cela va être l'idée et je ne
suis pas sûr du tout qu'on puisse dire
que benyamin nétanyahou soit
politiquement mort je pense qu'il est
temps pauvre alors selon radio qu'en
pensez-vous c'est vrai que c'est une
coalition assez improbable certains lui
donnent assez peu de temps et voit
effectivement le retour de benyamin
netanyhou plus rapide qu'on ne le pense
il faut se méfier de plaquer des schémas
de pensée français sur une des
situations étrangères n'en mangeait
toujours temps ça méfier des alliances
qui vont de l'extrême droite à la gauche
j'ai du mal à voir la viabilité en
termes de choix politique c'est laisser
croire qu' il ya des choix qui
permettent à ces alliances de durée
durablement je suis quelque peu
sceptiques et et au demain le rapport de
force effectivement et quand même du
côté de benyamin nétanyahou même s'il a
perdu le combat médiatique mais il était
très amoché pour des problèmes
judiciaires notamment difficultés
politiques une ligne dure mais il n'a
pas été loin sans faute désavoué par le
peuple
ça n'est pas une défaite électorale
c'est une défaite de mécanique partisane
je souhaiterais qu israël soit dans une
stabilité politique je crains hélas que
le jeu de netanyahu sera de déstabiliser
ce gouvernement et je crois qu'israël
n'avait pas besoin en ce moment surtout
au regard du contexte international dans
lequel ils le payaient pleinement inséré
nicolas tenzer oui je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le vrai problème c'est
que on n'a pas du tout d'unités de ce
gouvernement sur la plupart des sujets
que ce soit la question palestinienne
que je suis d'ailleurs même si rodez un
certain nombre de choix économiques sur
les alliances fondamentale du tout sauf
netanyahu quoi lasser voilà c'était
effectivement tsv atouts survie mais
c'est ça c'est sûr mais mais mais
aujourd'hui maintenant on a quelqu'un
effectivement comme bennet qui est
effectivement très adroite à l'ultra
droite mais qui était aussi quelqu'un de
pragmatique là aussi je pense que les
schémas sont un tout petit peu différent
c'est quelqu'un qui va malgré tout on
peut penser ne serait ce que parce qu'il
sera aussi largement contrôlé par celui
qui devrait en principe avoir beaucoup
de beaucoup de conditionnel bien sûr lui
succéder dans deux ans ailleurs la pid
qui lui est un véritable sens triste
c'est quand même la grille à la bid qui
a vraiment bâti cette coalition pour en
quelque sorte sauvé israël ben non il
faut voir aussi qu'il y a eu tellement
de dégâts faits par netanyahou en israël
sur le moral du pays sur son image à
l'international sur les choix politiques
qu'il a fait aussi par rapport au
conflit israélo-palestinien sur internet
année ou un autre ça a toujours été ça
oui voilà non mais quand même là je
pense qu'il ya vraiment quelque chose je
pense que netanyahou a quand même été
quelqu'un qui quand même dans notamment
avec cet aveugle ariel sharon c'était
pareil
oui mais il n'y a pas eu justement il
n'y a pas eu que 1 je pense que
netanyahou quand même aller très très
loin dans dans la droitisation c'est
quelqu'un même qui a donné en quelque
sorte un blanc seing
à ssa ii malgré tout il a toujours
essayé de jouer un jeu très très bizarre
alors que des autorités à la fois
religieuse et morale condamnait cette
espèce de choix de quasi neutralité par
rapport à la série
c'est quelqu'un qui a joué avec trump ce
qui était d'ailleurs très frappant c'est
de voir que trump amicaux pardon que joe
biden a mis un mois pour appeler
netanyahu alors que dans l'heure qui a
suivi il a immédiatement appelé bennett
ça aussi c'est quand même un signe c'est
à dire que on peut penser qu'il va y
avoir quand même en ré engagement contre
peut-être leur volonté d'ailleurs des
états unis dans la région
alors évidemment ce ne sont pas des
faiseurs de gouvernement ni des faiseurs
de rois il ya la dynamique propre de
aviserait alien mais je pense que les
états unis vont quand même essayer
d'appuyer assez fortement
alors qu'avait netanyahu ce qui était
extrêmement difficile et je pense que ça
c'est aussi une carte à jouer pour ce
gouvernement de profiter de cette
alliance avec une présidence américaine
raisonnable pour essayer de voilà deux
de contrer le jeu après il ya le dernier
sujet qui a évoqué florent tout à
l'heure qui sont évidemment les ennuis
j'ai dû judiciaire de netanyahou quand
même peut être que le fait qu'ils ne
bénéficient plus de l'immunité va
permettre enfin à ce que jugement puisse
s'approcher et finalement avoir lieu à
la lueur de tout ce qu'on s'est dit on
va que les cartes géopolitiques sont
quand même en train d'être sérieusement
revêtu un florent amadio
oui on vit une forme de d'instabilité
alors qu'il n'est pas nouvelle
instabilité hélas on la connaît depuis
déjà plusieurs décennies
là la grande différence c'est que il y a
certains conflits qui sont ouverts
l'exemple de la syrie avec de vraies
questions d'atermoiements des puissances
occidentales
d'autres qui sont masqués qui de ce fait
aussi par couardise pour éviter
d'assumer les lignes de fracture telles
qu'elles sont et face à cela il faut
vraiment que les responsables politiques
fassent une prise de position qui soit
dénué d'ambiguïté série ne faut pas
faire de la politique nationale avec
l'international ne faut pas essayer d'en
faire un thème de campagne pour montrer
qu'on a une stature présidentielle il
faut prendre des positions claires et je
souhaiterais vraiment que la campagne
présidentielle dans son approche des
élites françaises dans son approche de
l'international puissent prendre des
positions dénuée d'ambiguïté parce que
un responsable politique c'est aussi un
diplomate en en puissance et qu'il faut
savoir ce que feront nos dires
jean de ce monde extrêmement troublée
quelle alliance ils vont nouer et dans
quel but
pour conclure en 30 secondes nicolas
tenzer et je vends ce effectivement par
rapport à cette question là pas
uniquement sur israël je pense qu'ils
font de toute manière que la france en
particulier définissent des lignes
claires de politique internationale
joratel doit être beaucoup plus clair
sur les grands sujets russie chine afin
qu'elle ne fasse pas avec l'europe avec
l'europe qu'elle ne fasse pas je pense
dur en même temps je pense qu'avec la
russie la chine ou la syrie où des
régimes comme ceux là on ne peut pas
perdu en même temps la position sur
israël est clair je voudrais placer la
solution à deux états mais effectivement
pour revenir en israël je ne vois pas le
gouvernement actuel de l'accepter et on
doit s'arrêter là merci à tous les trois
merci car ligne directe et rose d'avoir
participé à ce match des idées sur deux
thèmes donc une fois n'est pas coutume
merci beaucoup et merci à tous les deux
c'est la fin de cette émission on se
retrouve demain à 18 heures et à 22h30
dans un instant auditions publiques
l'invité ce soir laurent berger
secrétaire général de la cfdt puis
demain matin 7h30 vous retrouvez bonjour
chez vous oriane continue recevra
notamment karima delli candidate de la
gauche unie aux régionales dans les
hauts de france
excellente soirée sur public sénat